et
[Musique]
devenez pas de fièvre électorale dans le
quartier de denis des zones hic
ici la campagne s'il est visiblement pas
les passions et dennis ne sais pas
encore pour qui voter ne lui en faut
plein de se prendre l'habitude de ni
vote pour les néo démocrates ou les
libéraux mais cette fois ci ils
pourraient choisir les conservateurs le
chef on
travaille dans le secteur automobile
depuis 28 ans et voit d'un bon oeil les
premiers secours à ford pour son
industrie
sa maison pour travailler sur un peu
doublage maintenant on a un futur ça
vienne du des consommateurs qui ont aidé
beaucoup
il est 15h à musique prince le de
windsor c'est la fin d'un quart de
travail et les ouvriers ils retournent à
la maison c'est aussi les indécis sont
nombreux
d'autres ont déjà pris leur décision
normalement fidèles ou npd il votera
blues cette fois ci
[Musique]
situé à quelques kilomètres de détroit
windsor et la capitale canadienne de
l'auto la région ouvrière des syndicats
y sont nombreux et la gauche
traditionnelle bien établie pendant
longtemps la région a été un fief néo
démocrates mais cette année le npd
pourrait y perdre des plumes et les
conservateurs y faire quelques prises
nos points ne cache pas ses ambitions
dans la région depuis des mois le
premier ministre sortant courtisent
ouvertement les cols bleus
en mars le gouvernement feint dhafra
d'efforts en concluant un accord pour
construire une usine de batteries de
voitures électriques
un investissement de 5 milliards de
dollars qui devrait créer 2500 emplois
fkc l'ieee le président du plus grand
syndicat de windsor parmi ses membres
beaucoup de travailleurs de l'auto dont
certains qui ont toujours voté à droite
free fight of the nine lives members
35% de nos membres votre conservateur
dit il un chiffre qui risque d'augmenter
avec la popularité de d'oxford
mais au delà du phénomène ford d'effets
constate un virage plus fondamental dans
le mouvement ouvrier et loyauté un parti
n'est plus ce qu'elle était et les
travailleurs de l'eau tous sont loin de
constituer un électorat homogène
[Musique]
sur le terrain et n'dri daoui constate
aussi ce changement de mentalité depuis
des semaines le candidat conservateur
dans onenote et komsic au newport sans
arrêt ça va bien ça va nous le
retrouvons sur la rue d'n'b dans un
quartier de l'est de la ville
conseiller municipal depuis 2014 njoum
il est au sein du parti progressiste
conservateur depuis des années
[Musique]
c'est sa première élection provinciale
en tant que candidat et l'ingénieur de
formation fait des pieds et des mains
pour charmer les indécis
à son programme de retour dans son
bureau de campagne n 12 se dit convaincu
d'avoir des chances de l'emporter j'ai
jamais
un joueur estime qu'il a besoin d'aller
chercher trois mille voix de plus qu'en
2018 pour battre l'ump guy un résultat
atteignable dit il maintenant cli
néo-démocrates n'ont plus le monopole
sur le vote des cols bleus je crois que
le npd a changé
le bureau de campagne de jamie gold on
met les bouchées doubles pour conserver
ce château fort
ici
absolument responsable de la campagne
s'attend à une course série c'est pas
normal pour un conservateur à avoir une
bonne chance pour être élu mais qu'ils
veulent mais kenzy est convaincu que son
parti pourra compter sur le vote d'une
majorité de travailleurs mr se veulent
se positionner comme un champion pour
les ouvriers
c'est pas la vérité
dans la circonscription voisine des
sexes eu un teddy fait aussi face à une
forte concurrence
claire un ancien policier nouveau venu
en politique provinciale se bat pour que
la circonscription reste oranje
je marche à peu près 16 km par jour
lance ron la course s'annonce serré mais
le candidat y confiant ce
qui est important c'est le style de
leadership
cette politologue s'attend à ce que
l'une pdi perdre au moins un siège dans
la région de windsor pour emmanuel riche
et ses luttes série révèle la
fragmentation de la coalition
néo-démocrates et le clivage urbain
rural de plus en plus marquée un duel
revanche n'a pas réussi à mobiliser à la
fois le vote des travailleurs et le voit
des actes et des activistes de gauche
qui habitent dans les centres villes de
la province
bien qu'un des six denis dernier ne
s'empêche pas de parler politique avec
ses voisins je pensais au fait de son
mieux marc marans tête un autre
travailleur de l'auto a pris sa décision
dans son comté il votera pour un parti
marginal de droite mais espère quand
même que les conservateurs formeront le
gouvernement je pense
[Musique]
un indécis et un électeur de droite
convaincu à 2 denis et marc prouve que
l'électorat ouvrier n'est plus acquis à
un seul parti à son paysage politique
change en les candidats devront ajuster
leur message répond aux attentes des
cols bleus et espérer que la récolte
sera bonne